et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés il y a l'imam directeur du
mensuel Afrique Magazine bonjour Ziad
bonsoir Afrique Magazine qui fait ça une
doute septembre sur DJ Snake à qui
Emmanuel Macron a rendu visite de
passage en Algérie et également sur
l'Afrique dernier poumon de la planète
grâce à ses forêt voilà pourvu que ça
dure oui parce que comme on est en train
d'en détruire un complètement il faut
essayer d'en préserver un autre et 200
millions d'hectares d'Afrique Centrale
et en particulier le bassin du Congo qui
est une des mais pas uniquement et des
forêts au Maghreb par exemple qui ont
brûlé cet été beaucoup il y a des forêts
en Afrique de l'Est il y a des forêts en
Afrique du Sud donc c'est ça fait partie
du patrimoine mais c'est un patrimoine
en danger pour les mêmes raisons
d'ailleurs souvent que en Amazonie
et également parmi nous notre
chroniqueur international sur France 24
Bilal tarabé bonjour Bilal bonjour
Raphaël et leur attendu le tout dernier
moment Michel Bachelet elles dont le
mandat à la tête Gio commissariat aux
droits de l'homme de l'ONU sèche faite
hier c'est au bout de la nuit dans les
tous dernières minutes donc elle a rendu
public son rapport il fait état de
violation des droits de l'homme aux
injean cette région autonome peuplée
pour l'essentiel de ouigo cette minorité
musulmane et turcophone pourrait même
faire l'objet de crime contre l'humanité
l'étendue de la détention arbitraire et
discriminatoire de membres des Ouigours
et d'autres groupes majoritairement
musulmans pourraient constituer des
crimes contre l'humanité voilà ce
qu'indique dans son rapport Michel
Bachelet via le moment choisi d'abord un
par Michel Bachelet pour pour plier ce
rapport in extremis avant son départ
alors qu'elle qu'elle avait jusque
jusque là plutôt montré pas de Blanche
semble-t-il lors de sa visite en mai
envers Pékin en disant sur le pouvoir
d'intimidation qui exerce la Chine il
faut ruser ou bien vous dites c'est déjà
une énorme preuve de courage finalement
et d'émancipation de la part de l'ONU
je nuancerais la première et je venus
entrer la deuxième partie de la phrase
c'est à dire c'est clairement un rapport
contre un membre du Conseil de sécurité
c'est pas aussi on connaît le pouvoir
effectivement d'intimation et de
pression de la Chine
ce rapport aurait pu être publié plus
tôt mais il a quand même été publié et
donc sans que ça soit forcément un acte
d'héroïsme absolument stupéfiant elle a
quand même sorti ce texte avant de
partir ça fera partie
j'allais dire de son héritage et bon
c'est en catimini c'est 10 minutes avant
la fin de son départ on aurait pu faire
ça un peu mieux on a presque d'après les
témoignages dans la salle de presse on
est arrivé on a posé des trucs et puis
on est parti c'est c'est explosif c'est
radioactif
mais en tous les cas le texte est sorti
donc le processus va tout tout les
répercussions autour de ce texte vont
s'enclencher se mettre en place et on va
en entendre
tous ceux qui militaient depuis très
longtemps pour la cause des Ouigours ont
un document officiel Nations unies sur
lequel on peut s'appuyer ça interpelle
quand même violemment le régime chinois
parce que on se doutait on pensait on
avait des éléments mais là encore une
fois c'est un document officiel donc il
y a une réponse chinoise qui pour le
moment est assez classique mais ça peut
ça peut pas rester absolument aucune
réponse ce rapport Bilel il dit quoi ils
se fonde sur quel témoignage bah alors
on va le faire point par point sur ces
principales conclusions donc le premier
point c'est que donc ce rapport dit
qu'il y a un schéma de détention
arbitraire au Chine Jong au moins de
2017 à 2019 dans des établissements
sécurisés la source ce sont des
documents émanant des autorités
chinoises alors Pékin présente ses
centres comme des centres de formation
professionnelle destinés à
d'éradicaliser des habitants du shinjang
mais selon ce rapport donc les raisons
de l'enfermement ce serait l'extrémisme
faut mettre des guillemets à tout ça et
donc ces formes des formes de cette
extrémisme c'est avoir trop d'enfants
par exemple porter un voile pour les
femmes ou encore avoir été condamné dans
le passé deuxième point ce sont des
accusations de torture alors elles sont
pas confirmées mais elles sont jugées
crédibles la source sont des personnes
qui ont été interviewées directement par
l'ONU ces personnes affirment avoir été
immobilisées ou battus et certaines
affirment avoir été violées ou avoir
subi des examens gynécologiques invasif
le troisième point ce serait la
limitation des naissances la source sont
là aussi c'est là aussi des entretiens
directs réalisés par l'ONU des femmes
ont déclaré avoir été contraintes
d'avorter si elles avaient dépassé le
nombre d'enfants autorisés vous savez en
Chine dépendamment des endroits et des
et des catégories de population il y a
un nombre d'enfants limité
la soi-disant évaluation que vous avez
mentionné est orchestré et fabriqué par
les États-Unis et certaines puissants
occidentales elle est totalement
illégale et invalide ce rapport est un
ramassis de fausses informations qui
sert d'outils politiques aux États-Unis
et à l'Occident pour utiliser
stratégiquement le gingembre afin de
contenir la Chine
accusation à désormais classiques de
propagande occidentale ça parle au pays
du monde en Afrique notamment au
Moyen-Orient qui ont des intérêts avec
la Chine
c'est compliqué parce que
il y a clairement la réponse est elle ne
veut pas être à cuire mais c'est assez
faible sur le fond de dire oui c'est les
Occidentaux qui ont monté un complot bon
on connaît un peu la musique ça illustre
quand même l'état de tension entre la
Chine et l'Occident qui est parallèle à
l'état de tension entre la Russie et
l'Occident à cette espèce de guerre
froide chaude qui qui se construit sur
plusieurs dossiers sur plusieurs
terrains on a dans l'histoire des ouigo
on a quand même des éléments qui
ressemblent beaucoup aussi au discours
contient en Russie sur l'Ukraine c'est
pas des vrais c'est des vrais russes
c'est les wigours ça devrait être des
vrais chinois enfin on a tous ces tous
ces points qui qui sont là après le
reste du monde
on pourrait en parler sur la Russie mais
on peut en parler sur la Chine c'est il
y a une espèce d'attentisme parce que
pour beaucoup de pays émergents les
enjeux sont tels en termes de j'allais
dire de survie économique de place
diplomatique qu'on préfère être un pas
en arrière et comment tout ça va évoluer
et d'ailleurs le cas des Ouigours est
particulièrement emblématique vous avez
pas entendu une seule grande puissance
entre guillemets musulmane venir au
soutien de ces populations donc on voit
très bien que et troisième point
là où il y a une faiblesse aussi dans le
raisonnement chinois c'est qu'on
pourrait très bien comprendre une
politique antiterroriste elle est menée
y compris en France aux États-Unis
partout on pourrait très bien comprendre
une politique anti-radicalité musulmane
ou autre ce qui rend les choses
absolument
contestables c'est c'est de prendre
l'ensemble d'une population et de dire
ils sont par nature radicaux où ils vont
l'être et ça c'est juste pas possible
après bon il y a le débat sur la
civilisation sur le fait que la
centralité de l'Empire il faut
absolument que tout le monde parle
chinois il faut absolument que tout le
monde soit éduquer de la même manière il
faut absolument tout le monde pense de
la même manière on accepte pas les
différences régionales culturelles etc
ça aussi c'est en marche mais c'est
aussi un peu en marche et beaucoup en en
Russie donc on voit à quel point les
deux les deux les deux réverbères
on va écouter la réaction européenne et
puis on viendra justement sur sur ces
réactions divers justement l'Europe qui
promet la fermeté écouter la
porte-parole de Joseph Borel
s
fermement les violations des droits
humains au signe et dans d'autres
parties de la Chine en particulier la
persécution des Ouigours et d'autres
personnes appartenant à des minorités
religieuses ou
ethniqueshang avec les autorités
chinoises depuis des années un forum
spécifique
est-ce qu'il y a pas un paradoxe à
entendre y compris l'Union européenne
dire qu'elle va dorénavant surveiller
plus étroitement le pouvoir chinois ça
c'est quand même assez fort voir l'ONU
finalement publié ce rapport et condamné
les éléments qui figurent et d'autres
pays d'influence au sein du monde
musulman des puissances comme la Turquie
comme l'Arabie Saoudite comme l'Iran
qu'on n'entend pas sur cette question ah
bah surtout la Turquie qui est
doublement concernée puisque les wigours
sont un peuple turc donc c'est à la fois
la même religion et à la fois la même
langue
la même racine oui bien sûr mais ça
revient aussi à dire que les pays arabes
les plus riches par exemple les pays du
Golfe n'ont pas accueilli de réfugiés
syriens enfin etc ça c'est on a quand
même dans le dans le monde
arabo-musulman et il faut quand même le
dire un discours de solidarité qui est
quand même variable en fonction des
situations et des intérêts de chacun
mais oui oui c'est totalement paradoxal
cela dit je voudrais juste préciser
quelque chose c'est que l'Union
européenne n'a pas attendu le rapport
des Nations Unies pour pour s'exprimer
sur le sujet je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez des shinjaunes police qui sont
donc des milliers de documents qui
avaient été piratés des fichiers de la
police chinoise et qui avait été publié
par un publié en résumé en analysé par
un consortium de médias internationaux
au mois de mai c'est Chine Giang police
ont fait grand bruit à Strasbourg et à
Bruxelles on a des euros députés qui ont
qui ont adopté une résolution alertant
sur un sérieux risque de génocide au
shinjan donc on est encore plus loin
là-dessus que que la rhétorique des
Nations Unies
on va peut-être passer à l'autre sujet
mais si l'Europe a vraiment les moyens
de ses ambitions en la matière c'est à
dire de
d'influencer et de peser sur Pékin sur
cette question on n'a pas les moyens de
faire changer Pékin mais on a un pouvoir
de la parole et un pouvoir de la
diplomatie et un pouvoir qui qui doit
nous autoriser à intervenir sur des
dossiers
qui sont enfin quand la teinte quand la
teinte est caractérisée je comprends les
zones grises quand on est sur des sur
des atteintes voilà on a des intérêts il
faut qu'on leur vende des avions faut
que ceci il faut que ça mais quand on
est sur quelque chose de caractérisé où
il y a des éléments caractérisés de ce
type là je pense que c'est absolument
nécessaire d'interpeller la Chine y
compris pour pour obtenir une réaction
un son quelque chose je peux me
permettre une seconde parce que alors le
rapport ne reprend pas le chiffre d'un
million de prisonniers Ouigours qui est
couramment repris dans les différents
rapports des différentes ONG mais
simplement pour donner un ordre de
grandeur de du sujet de
concentrationnaire voilà dans l'un des
districts du shingembre
dans l'un des districts des enquêtes
révèles que c'est 12% de la population
qui est dans ces camps
et d'ailleurs le groupe Renaissance ou
la plus grande j'avais voté une
résolution condamnant la Chine sur cette
question des ouigos il veut lui une
diplomatie justement plus sélective
Emmanuel Macron il a brossé pendant deux
heures devant lors de la conférence des
ambassadeurs toute une série de sujets
sur lesquels il entend marquer son
empreinte au plan diplomatique c'est un
peu vous qui étiez Bilal dans la matinée
à la fin de l'insouciance qui évoquait
le chef de l'État il y a quelques jours
absolument en fait il y a quelques jours
il
statuait la fin de l'abondance sur le
plan national et la fin de l'insouciance
mais là c'est clairement la fin de
l'insouciance sur le plan international
puisque depuis son dernier discours
qu'il a fait face aux ambassadeurs il y
a des années on a eu deux crises
mondiales le covid-19 et la guerre en
Ukraine qui sont venus percuter les
certitudes
occidentales et donc françaises sur deux
aspects le premier c'est l'économie
Emmanuel Macron l'a dit c'est la fin de
la mondialisation heureuse le la France
ne peut plus permettre de reposer sur
des chaînes d'approvisionnement qui font
trois fois le tour du globe ou pour
donner un exemple pour le coup
directement lié à l'Ukraine d'être
dépendant de tel ou de tels pays pour
pour des ressources énergétiques l'autre
l'autre l'autre jambe l'autre aspect
c'est le plan moral Emmanuel Macron l'a
dit le récit de la démocratie libérale
comme l'horizon de l'humanité
automatique ça ne marche plus et c'est
pour ça qu'Emmanuel Macron a insisté sur
la lutte qu'il faut avoir sous contre la
désinformation ou ce qu'il appelle le
récit narratif chinois rust turc alors
on va vous allez réagir on va l'écouter
alors non pas sur le premier le premier
extrait que j'avais prévu puisque tout
le monde on en a parlé sur le fait de
qu'il faut parler à tous vous aurez
l'occasion d'aller dans le commenter
juste après mais sur le le Summer
suivant qui concerne lui la question de
la souveraineté effectivement des États
qui peut parler peut-être un certain
nombre d'États notamment à africains
l'écoute les invariants et les moyens je
veux qu'on garde en tête c'est d'abord
le respect de la souveraineté de chaque
État et d'un son intégrité territoriale
je pense que c'est très important
d'abord parce que c'est le meilleur
argument que nous avons aujourd'hui face
à la Russie parfois nous avons pu
l'Occident a pu introduire le doute sur
ces sujets au nom même de nos valeurs
parfois avons-nous nous-mêmes par nos
actions documentées le procès que
d'autres nous faisaient à cet égard je
vais ici que ce soit clair c'est pour
moi un invariant on ne bouge pas le
destin des peuples en se substituant à
eux
on peut soutenir l'Ukraine sur ce
fondement là et se faire comprendre
entendre peut-être un certain nombre
d'États oui et non sur le principe il a
raison la souveraineté des États et si
on si on acceptait que cette règle soit
bafouée ici pourquoi elle ne serait pas
ailleurs et il l'a dit un peu plus tard
ou un peu plus tôt il dit bon courage à
la paix en Afrique si on si on remettait
en question en permanence les frontières
mais ça ça change pas le fait qu'il y a
une formidable ambivalence encore une
fois dans les Sud les Suds parce que il
y a pas il y a pas qu'un sud sur cette
guerre parce que il y a des gens qui
sont proches naturellement et
historiquement de Moscou et depuis très
longtemps parce que il y a des gens qui
pensent qu'après tout ça les concerne
pas parce qu'il y a des gens qui pensent
que le prix à payer pour le principe des
frontières pour eux ça se résume à une
énergie qui a explosé le blé qui a
explosé les circuits donc on peut pas
empêcher à certains relativisme et il le
dit lui-même quand on a fait l'Irak il
le dit pas vraiment mais je l'ai dit en
pointillés quand on a fait l'Irak et
qu'on a massacré la moitié d'un pays on
a du mal après bon ok tout ça c'est posé
ce qui est intéressant c'est que d'un
côté il dit il faut persuader l'Afrique
et de l'autre il a un long dégagement
Afrique positive et qui est passé
totalement inaperçu alors là il y a rien
vous pouvez regarder les sites tout ça
on parle d'eux mais il y a 12 minutes ou
presque sur il faut investir en Afrique
il faut soutenir en Afrique il faut que
la France soit présente en Afrique et
elle va et elle est en train de
rediscuter ces accords de sécurité pays
par pays pour éviter si j'ai bien
compris que des bases fixes
restent le modèle pour aller vers
quelque chose une intimité il a il a
utilisé le mot
intimité et ouais ben malheureusement on
a plus le temps
c'était juste pour pour expliquer qu'il
allait généraliser le modèle qui se
passe au Niger
que sous demande et intimité avec les
forces
et donc en concertation et en étant
évidemment en accord avec les objectifs
qui étaient plus le cas visiblement avec
la jante au pouvoir au Mali il a dit il
voulait pas de nous il nous mettait en
danger et il a dit autre chose
d'intéressant mais il a dit on est la
seule une des rares armées au monde et
en Europe trois ou quatre à pouvoir
faire ce qu'on a fait et à pouvoir
sortir comme on est sorti merci il y a
de l'imam merci également à Bilal
tarabes c'était ton va plus loin on se
retrouve dans moins de 3 minutes
[Musique]